what's up everybody how you doing today
in this video I want to discuss all the
potential epic battles that's going to
take place during season seven based off
all the reports that we have gotten dis
offseason we should see at least three
major battles and if you've watched any
of my breakdown videos then you know
that those battles have basically been
confirmed there are also a few other
historic fights that I want to mention
just in case we could see them during a
flashback scene so I'll start an episode
1 then I'll work my way to the season 7
finale reports started to come out
almost immediately after season 6 had
ended and in those reports there were
talks of our first major naval attack we
have seen some fleets under attack
before like at the Battle of Blackwater
Bay
we did see Stannis's fleet exploited by
a wildfire and we also saw ships in
marine get torched by Daenerys dragons
but we have yet to see a full-on naval
assault with ships of our ships well it
looks like we're finally going to get
that this season and who better to lead
the attack than your own gradually one
of the most feared and experienced men
on the sea after your own one the Kings
mood Yara and Filan took off with his
best ships and sailed right to Daenerys
to forge a new alliance before Euron
could get to her and when you're on
found out Theon and you're took off with
his fleet he asked his men to build him
a thousand ships because he still has
every intention of conquering the world
and now killing his niece and nephew
which is top priority we still don't
know exactly how many ships you're on
going to have but we did get a sneak
peek at what looks like his ships
silence so I imagine by the time next
season starts a good bit of time will
have passed that would allow your on to
have built a new fleet and have more
than likely already set sail and caught
up to his previous Ironborn fleet that
is now under command by Yara Greyjoy
I think season 7 is going to open up an
episode 1 with a Greyjoy civil war right
on the sea and your as fleet is going to
be absolutely decimated by your own we
know that Yara can hold her own weight
and she's more than likely going to have
the Martell fleet fighting by her side
who is also being led by ilaria san
which is another woman that doesn't take
no [ __ ] but they are no match for an
experienced veteran and psychopath like
Euron Greyjoy who may even have his
ships fitted with weaponry that we
haven't seen on the show yet you have to
remember
Euron has sailed all around the world he
one place is that most men fear so I
think it's safe to assume he could
reveal some things that other characters
in this show have no idea is even
possible in the books we know that
you're on has Dragan binder which is a
horn used to control dragons and I don't
know how many of you have read the new
chapters but he also has a suit of armor
that is made completely out of Valyrian
steel which I do hope we get to see in
the show you have to think if your on
goes into any battle wearing this
Valyrian steel suit of armor
it would probably almost make him
invincible no castle-forged steel is
going to cut through that armor and I
wonder if it would even protect him from
dragon fire the more I think about it
the more excited I get because your odds
introduction into the show was a bit
underwhelming but he has so much
potential to be one of the greatest
villains yet
I just hope Dan and Dave don't continue
to [ __ ] up his storyline depending on
how many ships he has he should wipe out
your affion and the sand snakes pretty
quickly especially if he has any other
kind of weaponry attached to his ships
that he may have gotten during his
travels that could be some kind of
projectiles or catapults that can sink a
ship with a single blow I don't expect
to see your own show any kind of mercy
to the Ironborn men that joined sides
with you ro and if you're on would have
caught Fiona and Yara before they formed
an alliance with Daenerys he would have
shown them no mercy either but now he's
going to use this as an opportunity to
form a new alliance with Cersei
Lannister who is already sitting on the
Iron Throne which is something that is
very appealing to your on but I also
think he's going to use Yara to
negotiate with and possibly use to try
and trap or ambush Dany or her men
Euron's going to be Danny's first big
test next season and after you're on
takes out the Martell and Greyjoy fleet
at sea that is going to obviously
decrease the size of Danny's army which
helps even the odds just a little bit
more for her adversaries but even after
Euron takes out some of her fleet her
army is still going to be too big for
anyone to totally defeat but if you can
chip away at it enough you can really
increase your chances of making this
thing interesting even though she still
has three really big guys dragons which
leads me to battle number two which is
going to take place right around
midseason this one begins with Jaime
Lannister leading the Lannister army to
a victory over the Tyrells in Highgarden
which is another part of Daenerys his
army getting defeated
by midseason all those new alliances
Danny made at the end of season six will
be completely irrelevant her Tyrell
Martell and Greyjoy forces are going to
be dead your own feelings still going to
be alive but they will no longer oppose
any kind of threat even though they
never really did in the first place but
at least they did have some men and
ships and if all the filming reports are
correct it seems as if Jaime and Bronn
conquer Highgarden without even breaking
a nail but it's what happens next that I
really want to talk about during this
time Jamie's going to strike a deal with
randyll Tarly who was once a supporter
of the Tyrells and if you're not too
familiar with randyll Tarly other than
just being sands [ __ ] of a father
there's one thing you should know
randyll Tarly is a legendary commander
arguably one of the best during Robert's
rebellion Reynold Tarly fought on the
side of the Targaryens and he actually
defeated Robert's forces at the Battle
of Ashford he then helped against
Stannis Baratheon during the Battle of
Blackwater Bay he was a top candidate to
be hand of the king but Cersei wouldn't
allow a Tyrell bannermen to get that
position so having rain totally on your
side would be a significant asset with
all these big battles coming up which
makes a nice addition for the Lannisters
at this point but if the reports are
right this new alliance is going to be
short-lived because when they are
marching back from Highgarden they're
going to get ambushed by Danny's forces
and this has the potential for being the
greatest battle we see next season it
has all the ingredients to be on a scale
of the Battle of the bastards they hired
hundreds and hundreds of extras and they
also got around 100 horses from this
battle scene so I expect to see some
carnage take place here and we are
finally going to see the Dothraki fight
in the open field if you remember back
in season one Robert Baratheon was very
nervous about the Dothraki making it to
Westeros because he knew exactly what
they were capable of and we may even get
to see the unsullied finally get to show
their true strength here because so far
they've been poorly used I know the
actor that plays his grey worm did show
up on the same set as Jaime Lannister so
we could see the lannister and Tarly
forces which are being led by one of the
most legendary battle commanders and one
of the greatest swordsman Westeros has
ever seen against the Dothraki an
unsullied who we've heard stories about
for years but have yet the full
see them shine and at some point during
this battle Danny is supposed to show up
with their dragons which will nearly
kill Jaime Lannister until he could save
by brawn this battlefield is going to be
littered with bodies and this is only
going to be in the middle of the season
regardless of how good or bad the plots
will be I'm very excited to see these
battles next season
each year they seem to get better and
better in my opinion and we're finally
going to see the Dragons go up against
main characters in their army this is
exactly what I've been waiting for
Circe's defenses are going to take a
major loss here making her even more
vulnerable to an attack on King's
Landing which gets us closer and closer
to removing her completely from power
just the thought of that alone makes me
smile but I've been wondering when this
battle takes place near the reach I
wonder if Jaime is going to be able to
escape if Daenerys and her forces defeat
them and her dragons burn the tarly's
alive I wonder how Jaime and Bronn are
going to make it out of here I would
think Daenerys would take them prisoner
because it would be very hard to escape
when she's on the back of a dragon she's
going to have an aerial view of the
surroundings which would give her a
bird's-eye view of the battlefield I'm
very curious how this ends and how they
would escape I'm wondering if she does
take them prisoner and we just haven't
heard about it yet this could play into
the big parler scene at the end if
Cersei and Euron have yara and the sand
snakes in Daenerys has Jaime [ __ ]
Lannister this could make for a very
interesting meeting during the season 7
finale
even though Euron was able to gain some
leverage after defeating some of Danny's
fleet out at sea and capturing some of
her allies once the nares takes down the
great Jaime Lannister and randyll Tarly
it's going to leave the Lannisters
without having many options at all what
move does Cersei really had to make
other than blowing up King's Landing so
there was no capital or Iron Throne I
don't see any other move for her unless
she would kneel and give it all up which
I do not see her doing no way in hell
but I am intrigued nonetheless but let's
move on to the next battle which will
take place north of the wall with John
George injury tormund hound barrack and
Thoros plus whoever these mystery
characters may be this one has potential
- whether you agree with the reasoning
behind John going north in the first
place or not just in terms of what this
may look like visually during the attack
a chance to be better than hardhome they
have to up the ante and raise the stakes
the closer we get to the end the crazier
these battles and attacks me to be so I
expect this to be the most action-packed
scene we've seen what the night king of
White Walkers debate even though John
has only taken a small group of men this
still should look spectacular
considering the men he is taking John
Jorah Foreman and the Hound alone are
top notch ass kickers and depending how
the meeting goes on Dragonstone between
John and Daenerys then all of these men
should have some dragonglass with them
plus John's Valyrian steel sword at
least I'm assuming John is going to get
some dragon glass while he's on
Dragonstone especially if he comes up
with this idea to go north of the wall
while he is there on Dragonstone and I'm
really hoping everyone that goes on this
white capture mission is equipped with
the weapon that can kill White Walkers
because they are going to need it
because I have a feeling they're going
to have to fight more than just some
lights the report that came out said
that they cast it over 300 people to
play as White's and then they're going
to digitally add in the rest it says
that they're going to be ambushed and
caught off guard and be surrounded so
they're going to have to fight their way
out of hundreds or thousands of whites
while the night king is probably just
overlooking the battle again watching
Jon Snow he's probably going to assume
that John has no way out of it this time
but John isn't just what someone of the
MIL wildlings this time he's with the
Westeros version of a SEAL Team six and
if you don't know what SEAL Team six is
they were the group of Navy SEALs that
took out bin Laden this episode should
be full of some epic badassery and
swordplay that I'm hoping takes up half
the episode like hardhome did but this
time we could see the knight king burst
dragons the Battle of Ice and Fire
ladies and gentlemen at some point in
this episode Daenerys is going to show
up on drug on with that least versary on
flying by her side if all accounts are
correct I can't wait to see the look on
the night King and White Walkers face
when they see dragons for the first time
I think their eyes are going to light up
like wildfire
and I know many people have hated the
way this scene goes down but this is
what I've been waiting for this story
has been building up towards the
ultimate conflict of vice versa fire the
others verse 2 dragons and we may
possibly get a taste of what's to come
early during season 7 now I don't know
if we're ever going to see an ice dragon
or not
but I'm not going to rule that out
because it does feel like they may go in
that direction we're just seeing the
night King and the dragons and the same
scene together is going to be amazing
I've been waiting for this day for a
very long time and I expect a night king
to have an ace up his sleeve
or else Daenerys could kill him during
this scene and the show would be over
and that would suck something must
happen in order to raise the stakes in
even the playing field someone is going
to come up with a defense against these
dragons so why wouldn't it be the maid
King the boss of all bosses I know there
are tons of people that don't want to
see any dragons die and they want to see
Damaris and Jon holding hands on the
back of drag on and fly off into the
sunset together but that is not going to
happen if you think this has a happy
ending then you haven't been paying
attention because Ramsay was right we
may see a dragon die this season and in
this scene so brace yourself for that
personally I would love to see a fight
amongst the Dragons
imagine John on the back of one of the
dragons and the knight King on the back
of one of the Dragons and then fighting
it out of the sky I think that would be
insane but maybe I'm just too much of a
fanboy or I get excited too easily
thinking about these things but to me it
would make things much more interesting
if the Mike King got his hands on one of
those dragons that would strike so much
more fear into Westeros because right
now the others don't seem like that big
of a threat to me
they're still stuck behind that wall and
Daenerys has three dragons that could
burn them all if she really wanted to if
there was no way for the night King to
take a dragon out of the sky then we
know he can't win in the end which would
really take the tension out of the last
battle during the Great War I think
things are way more exciting when it
goes all the way down to the wire and
both sides are pushed up against the
ropes at least that's what I'm expecting
to see in a bittersweet ending most of
the main characters are going to be dead
and will more than likely see the end of
magic I think we're going to lose some
people in this episode - I think Thoris
and Barrack are going to die and of
course uncle Benjen is more than likely
going to die saving Joe and just like
the league said so we're going to feel
some loss in this scene even though Jon
ultimately has a successful mission I
wonder what this is going to do to John
and Danny psychologically Daenerys is
going to see the threat for the first
time and we know she looks at her
dragons like they are her children how
is she going to feel if she not only
lose
a dragon but ends up having to fight her
own dragon and have to kill it again
then John is going to see his uncle
Benjen again but he almost looks like
he's dead
benjin might end up sacrificing himself
for John so he can live which we know
isn't going to sit well with John
because we know that John loved his
uncle Benjen knowing that he is now a
white would be traumatizing so I expect
to see the tone of the show to get much
darker after these things happen the
threat is going to be greater than ever
and we're going to have lost more
characters to the others and we've seen
from photos that snow is going to start
to fall in King's Landing already so we
probably won't see much sunlight from
here on out so it's going to get much
colder and the snows going to get a lot
deeper the stage is going to begin to be
set for season eight and all those epic
battles to come in the snow but before I
sign off there are two other things I
want to mention that could possibly be
seen during a flashback scene through
brand now that we got the Tower of joy
scene I feel like we may get some more
context to who John's parents were
they've shown us that the baby Ned
brought home was not from some random
woman he slept with but was actually his
sister Liana's baby but they still
haven't shown us any sign of John's
father or what his father was doing
while Leona was pregnant with John HBO
did release a graph that showed Rhaegar
was John's father but I feel like they
may give us a scene and show us who this
man was other than just going on for
what we have heard through legend they
could show us what happened to Rhaegar
and why he wasn't at the tower Sir
Arthur Dayne was guarding I would love
to get a flashback scene even if it was
just a brief scene of the battle at the
Trident which ultimately decided the
outcome of Robert's rebellion this is
what Robert Baratheon and Rhaegar
Targaryen fought to the death in which
Rhaegar lost they could save this for a
prequel show but I would love if they
gave it to taste of this now just
looking at the artwork for this thing is
incredible looking but the seed and
live-action would be even better to see
Robert Baratheon when he was still in
his prime carrying his big-ass Warhammer
that most men couldn't even swing but
also to actually see Rhaegar Targaryen
in person would be great to finally see
this man that drove people crazy and to
see his ruby filled armor then to see
Robert Baratheon bash in his chest with
his Warhammer so hard it sent those
rubies flying into the water it would be
a nice nod to the book readers
is one of the most important moments in
history that set up so many things to
happen if we don't get this then we may
see the 20 of harrenhal which is another
moment in history that set in motion the
story that we know today now I don't
know how much of this they would show
because it was actually several days of
jousting which Rhaegar won after he
defeated many legendary fighters and
although jousting is nothing like sword
fighting Rhaegar was able to defeat Sir
Arthur Dayne and Barristan Selmy who
were too savage fighters in their day if
they did show some of the tournament I
would love to see some of this jousting
but ultimately the most important part
is the meeting between Liana and Rhaegar
in his actions that day and after that
day which led that many wars to come and
the prince that was promised now this is
probably too much wistful thinking but I
hope to get a glimpse of some of these
things during season 7 they could keep
it short for time but just give us a
peek but I think I've rambled on long
enough
I just wanted to talk about some of the
big boss fights and battles we could see
during next season I also want to give a
shout out to cows [ __ ] chickens a
good friend of mine in this community if
you haven't already definitely go check
out his channel he has really started to
ramp things up by releasing multiple
videos a week that I think you guys are
going to like I also want to shout out
gray area who has a fairly new channel
but the quality of her content is
top-notch I highly recommend checking
out our channel you won't be
disappointed plus she's a really cool
person to talk to but anyway guys that's
my time for today thanks for stopping by
to watch this I appreciate the support
as always I will see you down in the
comment section bye